pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais associer à cette
question la sénatrice Christina pluschet
jeudi 19 janvier jour funeste pour
l'agriculture française la Cour de
justice européenne décide de rendre
illégal les dérogations prévues pour la
filière betteravière sur l'utilisation
des néonicotinoïdes le 30 octobre 2020
votre prédécesseur affirmé avec justesse
que la situation était perduement grave
et que tout devait être mis en oeuvre
pour protéger cette filière de même le
président de la République affirmait
haut et fort qu'il ne devait pas y avoir
d'interdit sans solution vous-même
monsieur le ministre vous m'affirmiez le
12 janvier être certain de la
reconduction des dérogations prévues
pour 2023
de plus en 2016 la France a interdit
l'usage de tous les néons nécotinoïdes
en aspersion ou en enrobage de semences
ce que l'Allemagne et tous les autres
pays s'autorisent la France s'est mise
dans l'impasse en 2020 la catastrophe de
la jeunesse de la betterave avait
occasionné 200 millions de pertes malgré
les engagements pris l'indemnisation n'a
été que de 10 à 30% du préjudice notre
souveraineté alimentaire est énergétique
et donc menacée quelle réponse concrète
le gouvernement entend apporter à cette
situation et à cette crise latente
monsieur le ministre il vous reste moins
de 10 jours pour apporter toutes les
solutions qui s'imposent car les
agriculteurs doivent prévoir leur semi
pour vous répondre la parole de tobinus
d'agriculture de souveraineté
alimentaire Monsieur fenot Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur recuit Perse vous connaissez
très bien cette question et je vous
remercie avec cette question de pouvoir
essayer d'éclairer le débat vous avez
raison il y a une décision de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne qui
s'impose à tous elle vient contrecarrer
disons-le un plan qui était celui sur 3
ans de sortir des néonicotinoïdes en la
forme autorisant la dérogation sur les
semences enrobées et en permettant de
déployer des solutions alternatives et
le programme était pour la troisième
année en cours cette décision s'impose à
nous tous vous avez raison on a très peu
de temps pour agir pour assurer les
planteurs vous l'avez dit aussi d'une
certaine force pour assurer aussi
l'ensemble de la filière je pense aux
industries qui triture la betterave et
qui sont importantes en particulier dans
votre département dans mais dans
beaucoup de départements de France
première élément garantir aux
agriculteurs qui seront couverts sur la
sur la paire de jaunisses on est en
train d'y travailler mais c'est bien ça
sur lequel on doit être au rendez-vous
sur la sous les jours qui viennent pour
les assurer qui pourront planter dans
des conditions qui soient des conditions
d'amortissement deuxièmement accélérer
encore
la recherche de solutions alternatives
soit dans celles qui étaient dans le
plan national de recherche je rappelle
qu'on avait mis plus de 20 millions
d'euros entre les acteurs de la filière
et l'État au travers de recherche que
melinra et qu'on travaille avec ma
collègue Retailleau et puis deuxième
élément d'essayer de travailler sur
d'autres recherches et d'autres
itinérateurs techniques avec des
molécules qui sont encore autorisées
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on expertise très
vite pour regarder les solutions pour le
coup en foliaire qui pourrait être
expertisé troisième élément vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur je maintiens
ce que a dit mon prédécesseur ce qui a
dit le président de la République et ce
que j'ai dit pas l'interdiction sans
solution la vérité c'est que cette
interdiction elle procède de 2016 le
principe de précaution à la charge de
l'environnement et d'être là de bien
avant donc c'est il faut qu'on assume
aussi les décisions qui ont été prises
c'est difficile pour tout le monde y
compris pour le ministre de
l'Agriculture c'est difficile surtout
pour les betteraviers moi mon sujet
c'est de leur donner de la visibilité la
visibilité c'est le plan de soutien sur
la jaunisse et c'est d'associer aussi
les transformateurs pour faire en sorte
que ils bénéficient des betteraves dont
ils ont besoin pour faire tourner les
outils de production nous allons y
travailler dans les jours qui viennent
nous nous sommes déjà à l'oeuvre
je récupère
je connaissais votre réponse mais il
faut des solutions et des certitudes
parce qu'au-delà de la compréhension
au-delà de l'impuissance française c'est
la colère c'est le désarroi c'est le feu
dans nos territoires c'est le saccage
annoncé de nos filières c'est la mise en
péril de l'industrie de sucre de
l'alcool du bioéthanol du gel
hydroalcoolique de l'alimentation
animale c'est le risque d'importation
massive de sucre ou d'éthanol notamment
du Brésil qui est produit avec des
produits que nous refusons ici en France
cet obéir c'est obérée la souveraineté
alimentaire et énergétique la France
devient le seul pays au monde à tous ces
interdits
la parole est à notre collègue
[Applaudissements]